chris hemsworth is one of those rare
actors who can do it all the Australian
star clearly excels in action films
considering he's the Mighty Thor of the
Avengers in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but he can also handle fantasy
comedy drama and even horror this kind
of versatility means that Hemsworth is
regularly unset and all those long hours
can even make the biggest movie stars a
little loopy well the results have been
caught on film here are some of the best
Chris Hemsworth bloopers juggling act
meal near Thor's mighty hammers
unmovable by pretty much everyone except
the god of thunder himself it's probably
the most famous object in Norse
mythology and certainly the most famous
tool in comics this side of Captain
America's shield or Batman's utility
belt
of course the hammer Hemsworth carries
around in all the Marvel films is just a
lightweight prop and apparently he can
toss it around and juggling quite easily
okay maybe not easily
[Music]
joke busters before the cameras roll
actors carefully memorize their lines
preparation is important for a good
performance of course but
familiarization with materials critical
in comedies if actors don't know what's
coming they're liable to laugh and ruin
takes now imagine how tricky it gets
once everyone is improvising on the spot
take the 2016 Ghostbusters for example
when Hemsworth had to describe why he
likes hot dogs contains old two food
groups dogs and buns director Paul Feig
encourages actors to try out ideas that
pop into their heads during filming and
even throws out suggestions himself but
sometimes when a joke is brand new it's
hard to deliver it with a straight face
I spent through a fire once didn't even
smell it it was in your house yeah and
once a bad case of the giggles has set
in there may be no coming back from it
fire was in your house yeah and the
whole house went down just say it
certain scenes in Thor the dark world
between Hemsworth and Natalie Portman's
character Jane Foster are tender and
emotionally powerful well they were
supposed to be
but do you know this know what I know
that that what come on Thor just tell
her how you feel
I don't know what happened to where you
were Huntsman hold ups Hemsworth plays
the title role in the Huntsman films the
action-packed adaptations of the snow
white folk tale collected and
popularized by the Brothers Grimm in
19th century Germany the films actually
take place long before that they have a
strong medieval fairytale vibe at any
rate it's long before the dawn of
mechanical flight which means Hemsworth
had to put the acting on pause whenever
filming was interrupted by
scene-stealing airplanes
the planes weren't the only things that
held up production unfortunately there
was one unset diva who wanted nothing to
do with poor Hemsworth
[Music]
and then there was those moments where
he had no one to blame but himself Pam
the worst piece of acting ever do a
little dance what if you witnessed one
of the strongest and most unbreakable
objects on the planet crack in half and
reveal itself for what it truly is some
flimsy little objects glued together
let's just say a little dancing solves
most problems cape gone wild the three
most defining characteristics of Thor
are the powerful hammer in his hand and
long blonde hair and his red cape that
ripples in the wind behind him well two
out of three ain't bad because on the
set of this standalone Thor film
Hemsworth's most temperamental co-star
was at cape
in addition to the cape issues on the
dark world set it apparently wasn't
clear to some people whether certain
scenes that finished filming or not I
believe you are and you want thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]